the german national anthem herald at the
start of the official ceremonies
in his address german president joachim
gauk looked back at the country's
successes over the past
23 years
via suzanne together we are unique
and on this day as we look around we see
what we've achieved
despite many difficulties and we're
grateful for what is developed
but gauk said germany needed to begin
playing a stronger role
in international affairs
german chancellor angela merkel agreed
the country had come a long way
and added that germany could not rest on
its laurels
there's still work to be done in the
former east german states
unemployment is higher and wages are
lower
but for millions of germans this was a
day of celebration
that 23 years ago the two german states
peacefully became one
i'm convinced it worked out well i had
relatives on my mother's side in the
east and never understood why there
needed to be a border between us
stuttgart is marking the occasion with a
street festival
celebrating all 16 german states
the motto of the event unique together